Wow,
the next part of the story,
there's some parallels with Abraham and
that's built into the narrative,
I think because Isaac is Abraham's
descendant and so we have to keep the
narrative echoing forward.
Otherwise it loses its,
it's continuity.
And um,
there was a famine in the land that
Isaac Isaacson and God tells him to stay
the course anyways,
repeating the promise.
He,
he gave Abraham,
although Isaac goes to Abdel Malek,
also telling the king and people that
Rebecca was his sister,
which is exactly what Abraham did when
he went to Egypt.
And so there's another echo there of the
same,
the same.
It's as if the story is being told for a
second time essentially.
And that's supposed to remind you of
the,
of the previous story,
but they're careless.
The king sees that Rebecca and Isaac are
intimate together.
And um,
luckily he doesn't have them put to
death.
He just tells everybody in the kingdom
that there to be left the hell alone.
And then Isaac prospers in that land,
just like Abraham did in Egypt until the
Philistines asked him to leave.
He's just getting too rich and powerful.
Things are going too well for him,
so he's asked to.
He's asked to leave.
Now,
in the meantime,
Esau gets married and this is a funny
little story.
He says he marries two women who give
grief to Isaac and Rebecca,
so they,
whoever he saw Mary's,
they're not popular with his,
with their in laws,
not in the least.
That actually becomes relevant a little
later because they drive rebecca quite
mad.
So I get a kick out of that because
that's very common.
You know,
it's not easy to integrate new people
into your family and hope that that will
go smoothly.
It's actually one of the real
catastrophes in life,
right?
You have a kid,
maybe you get along with them and maybe
you don't,
but let's assume you do,
but then they marry someone that you
just don't like and or maybe you think
is wrong for them.
I mean,
that's really rough.
That's what are you going to do about
that?
You know,
because you're,
you're basically screwed both ways.
If you have the person you love around,
then you have to put up with this
horrendous creature that they allied
themselves with.
And if you,
if you get rid of them completely,
well then you know you don't have your
child anymore.
So it's very,
very difficult position.
And so that's another example of the
realism,
I think,
of the stories.
Now,
Isaac,
who's hypothetically on his deathbed
asks Esl to hunt for Venison because he
likes venison and he's happy that his
son is a hunter and Rebecca overhears
this so she conspires with Jacob,
um,
to,
to slaughter to small goats and make his
father is some stew because he wants to
make him stew out of venison.
But Rebecca,
who's being,
I would say,
let's say slightly deceitful or horribly
lying that would be more accurate.
Um,
she conspires with Jacob.
Jacob kills two little goats kids and
boils,
APA stew.
And then he puts on some,
uh,
are goatskins because Esau was a hairy
character.
And,
and Rebecca Dresses Isaac in east
clothing because Isaac can't see very
well at this point.
And so then Jacob goes into his father
with the stew and he's trying to
disguise his voice,
but it doesn't work very well.
And so Isaac asks them to come close and
Jacob puts out his arm with the goat
skin on it and,
and Isaac smells him too.
And he smells like Esl and,
which maybe wasn't the best thing,
but,
um,
and feels like,
and so,
uh,
because Isaac thinks he's on his
deathbed,
he decides to deliver a blessing to
hypothetically to Esol.
And so,
but it's Jacob.
And so that's a big deal too because the
blessing is actually,
as I said before with these ancient
people,
it appeared as though once you said
something,
you didn't get to take it back,
you couldn't say,
well look,
you've deceived me.
So it doesn't count.
It was like I did.
They weren't maybe as
as
well,
week might be one way of thinking about
it,
but another way is they weren't quite as
attentive to context,
you know,
because if I make you a deal and then it
turns out that you betrayed me,
I may feel that the deal is no longer
valid because the assumption was you
were being honest to be given within
that violates the whole spirit.
But that isn't how these people thought.
They said once he promised man,
you promised,
and that was that.
So Isaac Blessed Jacob.
He says that God give you the dew of
heaven and the fatness of the earth and
plenty of corn and wine.
Let people serve you and nations bow
down to you.
Be Lord over their brethren that's going
to be rough on Esl.
Let thy mother's sons bow down to the
cursive.
Be everyone that curse if the blessing,
he blesses blessing.
And so there's a credit remarkable
painting of that.
So there's Rebecca,
she's looking pretty old and Isaac's
looking pretty blind and Jacob's taking
directions from his mother and we might
say he's perhaps a little old to be
taking more or lessons from his mother,
especially given how she's acting.
And so it's a pretty ugly scene
altogether,
especially that we also know that Jacob
already tricked Esau out of his
birthright.
And so now he's like taking the
birthright and he's taken the blessing.
And so as I said that Jacob,
he turns out to be the father of Israel.
It's like he's a reprehensible
character.
These are major league betrayals that
he's engaging and it's not trivial.
He really,
really pulls the rug out from under his
brother and you know,
you could say,
well Esl is not as awake as he might be.
You know,
he's kind of a wild man and fair enough.
But it certainly seems to me that,
that the predominant moral error falls
on Jacob's shoulders.
It's very treacherous behavior.
What he's doing.
So then Esau shows up and he's got a
Nice Steg for his dad and it's like
little late for that.
And he states that his brother was
rightly named Jacob,
which means supplanter because he's been
deceived twice and Isaac says,
Isaac answered.
He's,
he's asking for Esl,
was asking fundamentally if there's
anything at all leftover for him.
And Isaac can't give him the same
blessing because that's already been
given.
So he has to think of something else.
And Isaac says,
behold,
I,
I've made him my Lord,
and all his brothers I've given to him
for servant,
which includes you and with corn and
wine,
have I sustained him?
And what shall I now doing tv my son.
And Esau said unto his father,
how have you even one blessing for me,
my father bless me also.
And An esaw lifted up his voice and
wept.
And you know,
we already know that Esau is a pretty
tough guy by all appearances.
And you know,
he's out there hunting on his own and
camping.
And it's like he's no pushover.
And the fact that this reduces him to
tears is an indication of the magnitude
of the betrayal.
And Isaac says,
behold,
thy dwelling shall be the fatness of the
earth and of the dew of heaven,
from above and by Thy Sword,
thou shall live,
and thou shalt serve your brother,
and it shall come to pass when you will
have the domain Indian and you'll break
the yolk.
His yoke off from died neck.
And the Esol hated Jacob because of the
blessing where with his father blessed
him.
And Esau said in his heart,
the days of mourning for my father are
at hand.
Then I will slay my brother Jacob.
So fundamentally,
you know,
if Isaac dies or when he dies,
then we'll mourn for him.
And then Jacob better look the hell out
because it's like it's serious death
coming his way.